you've done something that very few
people have achieved if anyone people
love these superhero franchises now it's
the biggest thing going on the business
you this gentleman right here is in the
Marvel Universe and the DC Universe at
the same time here in spider-man Lewis
lair in the end you're on the harley
quinn animated series here in both at
the same time in two worlds at the same
time it's like having a Costco card in a
Sam's Club Card you know me the best
price has the best price that's why I'm
going go yeah sure this is huge I didn't
think people were allowed to be in both
universes but you can do it I can do it
but you got to do it it's got to be
animated it can be animated and we're
gonna be live see oh
number was I Ben Affleck he did play
daredevil and he did playback okay he's
done it - alright we're only two -
alright well yeah I do I do love it
here's my question for you would you if
you could choose would you rather be a
superhero or would you rather be a
supervillain would you rather be villain
I'll make the perfect villain you know
what come and sit talk see you think
that that would be yours of course I
would be you know what my skill si habla
gator a bunch of like like like Avengers
type a team a whole team of Avengers
like villains you know kinda like
Suicide Squad but yeah a little more
low-key like my powers wouldn't be dead
I'm gonna be that powerful I'm gonna be
like mediocre power really like what
kind of power would you have as a super
villain my villain name would be sucker
punch sucker punch
sucker punch uh-huh I got the dip of gab
when your guard is down I stuck a punch
away
good look at your slim washroom
[Applause]
see that coming you know I'll know
you're in ask how can mom doing who's
with sucker punch who's on your posse
it's a whole team of us in a nipple
twister one big shoe Reggie Jackson yeah
I got a guy called wedgie Jackson oh he
grabbed him underwear its grip is like
you lost me on that oh no what
less villains in just [ __ ] yeah yeah
love villains villains are my bang
you're gonna have a late you got to have
a lady you gotta have a lady gotta have
a lady well we have to you know one one
is a one is named miss miss mm-hmm
misunderstanding so she takes me down
this road she's emotionally she's off
crying in stuff because you did her
wrong he didn't wrong but it turns out
was a misunderstanding
I have to say I mean at first I thought
no but everyone seems behind this an
amazing team this is a main team the
whole city's confused amidst
misunderstanding that was Thursday no no
that picnics Friday misunderstood